in the two previous videos I mentioned
that I would upload a PDF I figured it
would be easier to just make a video of
the PDF in which I sort of narrate
different things about it so I mentioned
in one of the videos on the
monosaccharides I discussed the you know
deforms and L forms of sugars and their
alpha and beta forms and I talked about
how to manipulate them I didn't draw out
all of them but I do have them all drawn
out here so this glucose I've already
drawn that in the video I'm pretty
certain all the match up so I hope I
didn't do anything incorrectly but
everything here should be correct but
feel free to pause the video as needed
in order to sort of copy these down in
your own sort of notes um I'm going to
scroll through this very slowly but
notice that all the rules just sort of
stay the same it's kind of the best
thing to do I think is to just memorize
the D form of the sugars and be able to
manipulate them as necessary so that way
you end up memorizing things less you
just sort of remember the rules and how
to derive them and then things end up
being a lot easier I actually didn't
write in there that it the Alpha the
alpha L ribose I didn't write that here
but this is alpha L ribose so these are
all the sugars the monosaccharides
pretty sweet pun intended
alright but I hope this is a this is
helpful here notice with the deoxyribose
here I didn't actually draw the hydrogen
again so if a carbon doesn't have those
those drawings line those those draws
lined excuse me those lines drawn the
hydrogen's it's just implied to the
hydrogen's are there okay so here I made
a few notes I circled all the N america
carbons in pink so the beta and alpha n
numbers differ only at that end Americ
carbon otherwise they're identical the
beta H is always in the same side as the
Box CH 2 which I boxed in green and the
Alpha alpha
Oh age group on the anomeric carbon is
always opposite the the ch2oh group okay
the dnl sugar as I mentioned before a
different stereochemistry at all the
chiral centers so basically anything
that was up in the D form is down in the
L form
vice versa so as I mentioned before the
tip as far as how to remember all these
this is just memorize only the D form
especially since they're the ones that
exist in biological forms then if you're
asked for the L form or if you somehow
want to draw it on your own then just
simply make all the all the the the
groups opposite okay I already had a
video on the disaccharide as well but
I've drawn them here might be a little
bit neater notice I've drawn here as
drawn in lecture slides the reason why I
did that because I've taken classes
obviously in biochemistry and that's how
it was presented to me now if you look
up maltose you'll see that there's an
alpha and beta maltose if you just look
it up on Wikipedia you can find that or
Google just in general but there's alpha
and beta maltose here I think I believe
I've drawn beta maltose so there's an
alpha male so you're interested about
that structure but like I said feel free
to pause the video as needed to you know
draw things out or take notes the video
the video I made right before this one
is on the disaccharides so and
polysaccharides here though I've all I
stopped drawing at cellulose I didn't go
on further
but again just pause as needed rewind as
needed do what you got to do and learn
alright guys thanks for watching